Avrupa'da giderek daha fazla vatandaş ve
biz sosyal sözleşmenin
bozulduğunu düşünüyoruz ve Trump'a oy verildiğinde ve bozulduğunda görüyoruz
ve
çevrenin bozulduğu ve servet
ve gelir eşitsizliğinin
tarihi boyutlara ulaştığı bu resimlere baktığımızda da görüyoruz.  Birçok kuşakta ilk kez yüksek seviyelerde
insanlar yakın gelecekleri
konusunda ebeveynlerinden daha az iyimserler
ve bu konuda
şirketleri veya en zengin insanları suçlayabiliriz
ama
bence kendimize ve toplumumuzu nasıl yöneteceğimize ve nasıl davranacağımıza bakmalıyız.
harekete geçmekte daha cesurum hikayem ve bunu neden kısaca umursayayım çünkü seninle
biyografimden ziyade bir fikir hakkında konuşmak istiyorum ama
burada İstanbul'da büyüdüm ve
16 yaşımdayken bir yıllığına bize gittim ve ben  Burada
ayrıcalıklı bir lisede çok çalışıyordum
ve sonra orada
birdenbire insanların o
kadar fazla çalışmadığını ve gerçekten
eğlendiklerini ve oradaki ebeveynlerin
de güzel olduğunu gördüm.  İyi bir yaşam tarzın ve eğlenceliydi
ve sonra geri döndüm ve
buradaki hayatın üniversite sınavlarına hazırlanman için çok daha zor olduğunu fark
ettim
ve bu yüzden tamam dedim
neden bu kadar farklı
bu daha iyi nasıl yapabiliriz bu yüzden ben  mühendislik
derecesini aldım Balaji'ye gittim
Mühendislerin dünyanın sorunlarını çözdüğünü
düşündüm ama kısa süre sonra mühendislerin
hissedar değerini en üst düzeye çıkarmaya çalıştıklarını ve toplum için
en önemli olan şey üzerinde çalışmak zorunda olmadıklarını
öğrendim
.  doğru politikalar uygulanıyor, bu yüzden
birkaç yıl boyunca McKinsey ile bir
danışmanlık şirketi için çalışıyorum ve
oldukça yararlı olan kapitalizmle tanıştım ve
ardından
Berkeley'de çok sayıda
harika politika çalışması ve içgörü yaptıkları bir politika diploması aldım,
ancak hayal kırıklığına uğradım.
Bu içgörülerin çoğunun
ABD'de politikayı tanımlamada kullanılmadığını keşfettik
, siyaset yapma şeklimiz daha çok
kimden hoşlandığımızla ilgili.
dilekçeler yeniden seçilmeli
ve çoğu insanın
duymaktan hoşlandığı ve medyanın
daha ilginç olanı ele almak istediği şeyleri söylemeleri gerekiyor,
bu yüzden
yeni başlayanlar ve Teknoloji olan başka bir rotaya gitmeye ve
teknolojiden yararlanmaya karar verdim  sosyal iyilik yapmak için
yaptığım ilk şey
, beni Danimarka'ya götüren Danimarka'da bulunan bir kitle fonlaması platformuydu, bu
yüzden
şimdi 11 yıldır Kopenhag'da yaşıyorum ve bundan sonra üç yıl sonra karar veririz adı verilen
doğrudan demokrasi platformunu başlatmaya karar verdim.
Çok hırslı olan bu işi yapmak
için rota değiştirmeye karar verdim,
birkaç yıl sosyal finansla çalışıyorum ve sonra bu şirketi kurdum,
beni bir bisikletimizle görüyorsunuz,
eşek Cumhuriyeti
denilen 5000 bisikletle
Avrupa çapında ve yaklaşık olarak paylaşılan bisikletlerden biri.  50
destinasyon
, şimdi bir platform olarak genel hedeflerimiz hakkında düşünmenizi istediğim fikrine gelelim
bu ne anlama geliyor,
bu g  hedefler
eğitim sağlık boş zaman vs.
gibi ve üzerlerine fiyat etiketi koymalıyız
bu hedeflere fiyat etiketi koyabilmeliyiz
çünkü dev kamu bütçelerimiz var ve
onları değer verdiğimiz şeylere harcıyorsak
biz de olmalıyız  onları
ölçmüyoruz çoğu zaman değiliz ama
bunu yaparsak yapabileceğimizi varsayalım ve bunu
yaptığımızda aslında
bu kamu hedeflerine hizmet etmek için pazarlar açabileceğimiz fikri
bu size iyi bir eğitim vermek istiyorum
bu kamu yararı
bir değeri olan çocuklarımıza verdiğimiz gibi, bu
fiyat etiketi nedir, kamusal alanın değeri nedir,
daha fazla kamusal alan olduğunda hepimizin zevk aldığı
kamusal alanın değeri nedir?
ya da
bürokrasi ile bundan ne gibi bir değer elde ederiz
ki bu sistemi ayarlamak
gerçekten işe yarıyor başka
örnekler ekleyebilirsiniz tüketiciyi koruma düzenlenmiş
pazarlar daha fazla ağaç
kirliliği vb. bu yüzden
kamu hedeflerinden bahsetmek
istiyorum  sol taraf ve kullandığımız tüm bu
hizmetler ve mallar aslında bu kamu hedefleri
üzerinde etkileri var
eğer araba
kullanırsanız hava kirliliğine katkıda
bulunursunuz bisiklet sürerseniz bunu
yapmıyorsunuz ama biz yapmıyoruz  bu hizmetleri ve malları düzenlemek için
gerçekten geri gelen ödül ve cezalardan oluşan bu geri bildirim döngüsüne sahip
olabiliriz ve
sanırım yaptığımızdan çok daha iyisini yapabilir
ve ekonomistlerin bu dışsallıklar dediği şeyi içselleştirebiliriz,
yani kısaca
yine burada bisiklet kullanırdım  80'lerde
ve 90'larda bu kasabada eğlenceli bir spordu
ve sonra Kopenhag'da şimdi
işe gidip geliyorum Her gün karnında bisikletle çalışmak 25 dakika İşe
gidişim bir buçuk saatti
, otobüs vapuru ve  başka bir tramvay yolculuğu
ve annem aslında
yapması gereken 40 yıl çalıştı ve çoğunuz
muhtemelen hala
işe gitmek için bir buçuk saat çalışıyorsunuz, bu yüzden bisikletler
aslında bir şehrin yatırım yapabileceği harika şeylerden biri
çünkü  T  hey
birçok sosyal faydası var ve
özellikle
demiryolu ağıyla birleştirilirse oldukça hızlı olabilirler, bu yüzden bu
aslında bisikletin belgelenmiş etkileri
güvenli sokaklar sağlıklı insanlar hızlı
hareketlilik düşük gürültü seviyeleri düşük hava
kirliliği ama biz bisikletleri teşvik
etmiyoruz  bisikletçilere bisiklet için ödeme
yapmıyoruz bisikletleri sübvanse etmiyoruz benimki
gibi bisiklet paylaşım şirketlerini sübvanse etmiyoruz
bu yüzden
bir toplum olarak sahip olmamız gereken kadar çok bisiklete veya bisikletçiye sahip değiliz
ve bu birçok başka
şey için geçerli bu yüzden  neden oluyor bu Los
Angeles 1907'de bir bisiklet otoyolu vardı
dünyanın en iyi bisiklet
altyapılarından biri o zamanlar
da iyi bir tramvay altyapısı vardı
ve bu bugün Los Angeles
teknolojinin sadece bir şeyler yapacağını varsayıyoruz
bizim için daha iyi ama teknoloji sadece teknolojiden
ne istediğinizi tanımlamanız gerekmez,
burası Kopenhag Kopenhag'da
bir sürü yüksek teknoloji ürünü
varken Los Angeles'ta seyahatlerin %80'i
Kopenhag'daki araba yaklaşık %20'dir ve
tüm yolculukların %50'si bisikletlerle yapılır çoğu
motor yüksek obezite seviyelerine ve
yüksek şiddete sahiptir ve Kopenhag
düşük obezite ve şiddet ile dünyanın en mutlu şehrine sahiptir
şimdi otonom veya
sürücüsüz araçlardan bahsediyoruz  ve insanların bundan keyif
aldığı şuna benzeyen sokaklara sahip
olabiliriz ya da uygun olduğunu düşündüğünüz veya istediğiniz resim bu olmadığı için biraz daha böyle görünebilir
, sorun şu
ki politikacılar politika yapmak için tartışırken biz bunu yapmıyoruz.
Los Angeles'ın
şiddet ve suçla nasıl olduğunu ve
araçlarla nasıl ilişki kurduğunu karşılaştırmayız ve değiştirmeye karar
veririz, kimlerle özdeşleştiğimize bakarız ve
buna inanmak isteyip istemediğimizi bilebiliriz
.  Yani demek istediğim şu ki toplum
olarak biraz daha teknoloji şirketi gibi davranabilir
ve şeffaf bir şekilde çok daha fazla veri toplayabilir miyiz
bu göstergelerle bağlantılı
Sağlık istihdamı mutluluk boş zaman
her şey  topluca önemsiyoruz
ve onu hizmetlere ve
mallara bağla,
insanların yeni hizmetlerle katkıda bulunabilecekleri
ve bunun için ödüllendirilebileceği bir platform haline getiriyoruz ve
sosyal hedeflerimizi reddediyorsanız, o zaman bunun
için ışık cezasını çekmelisiniz
.  Sanırım bizim bike shake şirketimiz gibi
tamamen yeni bir şirket türü
ortaya çıkacak, belki bazı şirketler bazı halka açık
parklar veya daha önce duymadığımız bazı yeni yaşlı hizmetleri kuracak
, oh diyebilirsiniz ki
bu bir tür kurumsal sosyal medyaya benziyor.
sorumluluk ama bu tamamen
farklı bir şey çünkü bunlar artık
sürekli bir şekilde kamu geliriyle finanse edilecek iş
modelleri bunlar pazarlama gösterileri değil ve bence
hükümette eksik olduğumuz başka bir şey de yetenek, nasıl çekeceğimizi bulmamız gereken yetenek
Google'da veya bazı pazarlama şirketlerinde çalışan insanlar
, gerçekten bildiğiniz yetenekli beyinlerini kamu yararına kullanmak için kullanıyorlar,
belki
onları düzenleme tasarlamaya veya teklif vermeye ikna edebiliriz.
o Düzenleme geleceklerine bahse girin veya teklif verin,
bunların şimdi nasıl kamu sonuçları
yaratabileceği bazılarınız için bir kara ayna
olayı ya da gerçekten olumsuz bir şey gibi gelebilir
ama sanırım
ne olduğuna bir göz atmalıyız.  mümkün, öyleyse
neden benim gibi bir adam
bu çılgın fikirleri ortaya atıyor, bu şeylerin bir kombinasyonu
ama çok kısaca
CO2 emisyonları
hakkında birkaç on yıl önce bu üst sınır ve ticaret sistemini kurduk
ve bunun büyüleyici olduğunu düşündüm.
Emisyonlarınızı azaltan bir
şirketseniz ödüllendirilebilirsiniz
, bunu yapmazsanız
ceza alırsınız bahsettiğim her şey
CO2 emisyonu ile tek boyutta uygulamaya konur o zaman
kısaca sosyal etki tahvilleri ile çalıştım
ve bu aynı zamanda oldukça ilham verici oldu
sosyal etki tahvilleri, hükümet
hey burada bir sorunum var dediğinde,
nasıl çözüleceğini bilmiyorum, bu
sorunu piyasalara açmak ve benim adıma çözmek istiyorum
ve bu hedef grup
için  nd Yaptığınız her iyileştirme için size şirketlere belirli bir
miktar para ödeyeceğim
ve bu projelerden biri
aslında
on yıl önce Birleşik Krallık'ta başlatılan ilk proje
, eski mahkumların gerçek hayranlarını azaltmak ve böylece şirketlerin
eğitmek için hizmetler sunmasıydı.  bu
insanlar hapishaneden çıktıklarında daha iyi bir yaşam sürmeleri için mahkumlar
çünkü
görünüşe göre birçoğu
dışarı çıktıklarında o kadar iyi fırsatlara sahip değiller ve
çoğu zaman yeniden suç işleyip tekrar
içeri giriyorlar bu yüzden 10.000 veya X tutarında bir bütçe ayırıyorlar
aslında marjda devam eden kişi başına
daha iyi bir yaşam sürdüren kişi sayısı arttı
şirketler bu parayı
evsiz insanlarla başka bir projeye
koyabilirlerse hayatlarını sürdürebilecekleri bir eve yerleştirilebilir bu
olumlu bir sosyal sonuç başka
biri insanların yaşam tarzı
alışkanlıklarını değiştirmek ve diyabetin önlenmesi ile
diğeri
ise istihdam veya eğitim dışında kalan gençlerle çalışmak ve
onları aynı zamanda işe almalarını sağlamak.  daha iyi bir
durum aynı zamanda olumlu bir sosyal
sonuçtur ve bunun için ödemeye hazırız,
o zaman başka bir ilham
kaynağı birkaç yıldır teknolojiyle çalıştığım şirketler ve
ince bir şey var bu
muhtemelen hepinizin bildiği gibi Facebook'un açılış
sayfası  Facebook'un
sonuçları iyileştirmek için yüzlerce test çalıştırdığı, dolayısıyla
Facebook'un
içeriğimizle bu platforma katkıda bulunduğumuz bir
platform olduğu ve
sonuçları iyileştirmek için bu testleri çalıştırdıkları,
sonuçların kaç saniye olduğudur.
platformda harcama yaparsınız
, sponsorlu içeriğine tıklarsanız,
daha fazla içerik paylaşacaksanız veya
etkinlikler oluşturacaksanız vb. Uyguladıkları
test
, kullanıcı arayüzündeki değişikliklerdir veya bu olabilir.
size gösterileceklerin veya
bildirim kalıplarının ve izledikleri şeylerin algoritmalarını
değiştirirler, umursadıkları sonuçları nasıl değiştirirler
hakkında ve bu
pek çok teknoloji şirketinin yaptığı bir
şey buna inşa ölçü
öğrenme döngüsü deniyor bu döngü
fikirlerle gelip onları bir ürüne koyarsınız
, aslında ne yaptığınızın etkisini ölçebilmek için verilere sahip olmanız gerekir
az önce yaptım ve sonra bu
verilerle öğrenebilirsin, istediğin sonucu yaratıp yaratmadığını anlayabilirsin
, bu döngüden
ne kadar hızlı geçersen o kadar hızlı öğrenirsin ve
Facebook'u ve en büyük teknoloji
şirketlerini şimdi bu kadar hızlı büyüten şeyin ne olduğunu anlayabilirsin.
Dünyanın en değerli on şirketi,
çünkü bu döngüden gerçekten
hızlı geçiyorlar ve biz bunu kamusal alanda yapmakta çok yavaşız,
bu yüzden Facebook Google ve
Apple dijital olarak doğmuş platformlar
ama Tesla Amazon Airbnb gibi başka bir şirket türü var
ve onlar
getirdi.  daha önce çevrimdışı endüstriler
, çevrimiçi perakendecilik ve konaklama işletmesine dönüşüyor,
bunlar eskiden çevrimdışı
işlerdi, ancak artık politikalardaki her değişikliğin nasıl olduğunu takip edebilirsiniz.
Bu platformlarda insanların davranışlarını değiştirmek
Bence çok
karmaşık sosyal refah sistemimizi bir platform olarak alabiliriz
testler veri [ __ ] ve
bu teknoloji şirketlerinin yaptıklarını yapar
çok daha iyi bir durumu iyileştirmek için üst düzey yetenekleri
cezbeder
, temelde toplumu iyileştirmekten bahsedemezsiniz.
şirketin rolüne değinmiyorum burada
Apple çok saygılı bir şirket gibi görünüyor
Apple ürünlerini sevinçle kullanıyorum ve
diğer şeylerin yanı sıra vergi
kaçırmak ve insanları
gerçekten kötü koşullarda
çalıştırmakla suçlanıyorlar ama Apple'ı suçlarsanız bir noktayı kaçırıyoruz ve  şirketler
bu tür şeyler için
yasa dışı bir şey yapmıyorlar ve
şirketlerin kendilerini düzenlemelerini bekliyorsak
, hissedar değerini en üst düzeye çıkarmak için
çok safız, bu yüzden uber
gidip işçi haklarını veya
taksicileri temsil etmeyecek ve bunu yapmak zorundayız
toplum olarak paranın sosyal değerle daha az ilişkili olduğu bir zamanda yaşıyoruz,
öyle görünüyor ki biri zenginse biz
biraz ihtiyatlıyız ne yaptınız
bu kadar parayı kazanmak için kimle uğraştığını biliyorsun
ve bizim de
paranın toplumsal değeri temsil etmesi için kamu çıkarlarını temsil eden sağlıklı düzenlemelere ve düzenlemelere ihtiyacımız
var, bunun bir yandan tartışmalı şeyler olduğunu söyleyerek konuşmamı bitireceğim.
tüm kamu mallarını iki pazara açın diyor
hükümetle
çalışanlar muhtemelen hayır diyecekler bu çılgınlık
ve tüm serbest piyasa
her şeyi düzenle diyecekler ki bu da çılgın
ama cesur olmamız lazım
bir zamanda yaşıyoruz  teknolojinin hızlı hareket ettiği yerlerde
, her vatandaş daha iyisini yapmıyor
ve daha cesur olmalıyız ve
oraya çıkmalı ve
işleri nasıl yaptığımız konusunda meydan okumalıyız
Teşekkürler